subject for today
is force oh you you really you think
you're women you should be forceful
there you go i don't think you said that
perfect subway because uh today we're
going to be talking about how
chris cuomo has me tood himself
half asian lawyer bill richmond is not
here so hold on let me see what do you
have to say bill
okay oh wow supporting communist china
again are we bill he did send us that vo
yeah
yeah what are you what's going on bill i
don't know what
okay oh okay that's racist um
so i woke up today so happy and we're a
little late because there was breaking
news it has to do with the portland
mayor yeah no okay i can't i just
if i were to die right now it would take
four hours to wipe the smile off my face
in one morning it sets in i get to see a
portland mayor
who's now leaving his condo uh because
of
the consistent attempts to burn it down
yeah and i bet you he wants people
to believe that it's yeah it's the it's
the proud it's the uh the patriot prayer
with a bowling ball candle under his uh
it's gotta be those guys chris cuomo the
recorded call that leaked he's basically
me tood himself
and then brian stelter we get to fact
check just because he
there's there's wrong and there's fact
checking there's nuance and there's just
saying the exact
opposite of what is true and stealther
is the gift that keeps on giving you
call it stealthering it is a stellar
effect i hate that his face is the sun i
would i would not live on that planet
what would steltering be would
sheltering just be geez
no integrity they have no journalistic
integrity so
nuisance money my question is have you
guys heard of the phone call between
uh chris cuomo and mr cohen and uh what
do you think does he sound guilty
of anything and should he be held to the
same standard and he has asked you to
let him know and tweet him so we will
encourage you to do so but of course
being civil
after this before we move on of course
please do consider joining mug club
that's what allows all of this to take
place live with cutter.com club and we
are available
uh on audio on spotify on apple
on android all those podcasty places
used to be called the itunes
yeah um everywhere oh but before let's
go to cnn really quickly here they're
talking about from eviction
through the enemy oh so they moved away
right now they just had
trump slams pelosi for haircut no you
should be slamming pelosi
right for the haircut and we will be
very soon we have so much to get to i
have
it can you see this that's a big smile
this is this morning
it's it's actually more effective than
years of therapy oh
it's like it's like botox i feel like
they just lowered me into a pool of
electric water on shutter island
and i came out and everything is a new
and the the
sun is bright and the birds are chirping
and chris cuomo's career
is going to be done i felt like you were
going to lean and go do you know how i
got this smile
what are you doing different uh he
decided to ruin it two films so
two different let's go to uh really
quickly off the top this is important
because
it affects all of us yeah i want to make
sure i get this correct because people
have a thing about their usernames yeah
a youtube user uh
penguin z number zero i believe not oh
so number zero
uh had a video taken down and i want to
be clear uh
the video was taken out but we've
actually blurred the portions in context
he had a video taken down on youtube a
heart strike video actually removed i'm
not sure it was a heart strike but
removal used to account for used to
include a hard strike for a fake
fight video and this is the video in
question
and it's not even a real fight video so
youtube officially confirmed with a
statement saying
uh confirming that a member of the team
reviewed the video in the decision
stands footage containing graphic
content fight speeding etc
with intent to shock uh it violates our
community guidelines markiplier a big
youtube
youtuber said uh fair is fair team
youtube where's my
strike answer us youtube is trending and
i would like you to send that answer as
youtube is trending because here's the
concern right now
um this will directly affect news
outlets trying to be accurate or
programs trying to be accurate more
specifically
conservatives trying to be accurate
here's why because let's take kyle
uh kyle kenosha kyle rittenhouse kenosha
he's really
he's known as paul sheboygan very big in
sheboygan
we've covered the shootings there and we
always tell people this is graphic same
thing with david
now channels have covered ad nauseam the
george floyd situation
yeah where according to the medical
report no one was actually killed
because of a knee on the neck it was
because someone overdosed and actually
had a heart condition so everyone has
shown that video
but like i've talked about yesterday if
someone is talking
about an incident where there is clear
videographic evidence especially if
there are multiple angles
like you have with kyle rittenhouse and
kenosha and they don't show you the
video
they are likely lying so when you have
the young turks or you have cnn going
out there and saying well kyle written
house went out and gunned down his
victims that's a very different context
of course
than the victims bashing him in the head
with a skateboard or running up on him
with a gun
some of whom are noted repeat child sex
offenders uh
what does it mean for shows like we are
the kind of program that shows you
context specifically that is kind of a
conservative value the idea of
transparency
the idea of allowing people to make
their own decisions we've had more
opposing voices on
this show we've done changed my mind
we've done i've changed my mind recently
with tesla
yeah we've had debates on this program
we've tried to be fair we've tried to
show both sides we use
more leftist sources than anybody else
but what is youtube going to do now for
channels like this
if we are showing actual video and
blurring out we don't show the actors
yeah but what is that a violation if cnn
msnbc abc nbc cbs if they all go out
there saying kyle rittenhouse gunned
down a victim and we go no no hold on
wait
here's video and then youtube says by
the way we're removing the video
that's the concern yeah absolutely
basically it's just a catch-all anything
that we don't want out there anything
that doesn't fit into the narrative that
we are supporting we can just
claim oh it's because of this policy
that we have now and we're covered
because we're taking it all down
it doesn't make any sense they want to
remove the exact
tool that uh ended up uh giving
nick sandman um redemption they want to
remove the exact tool of people saying
here's more video of the conflict they
want to remove the exact
tool that would prevent an innocent man
from being falsely charged cal right now
which is the new york times admitted
i don't know where this goes with
youtube yeah youtube is making it easier
for creators to lie to you
right and yeah harder for you to
actually get the truth right
and by the way tune in to all the
leftist channels that you can find on
youtube and there aren't many that are
doing that well
but uh you know i hate to resurrect the
dead but the young turks
they talk about the kenosha shooting
kyle rittenhouse never
once do they show you all the clips they
did initially when they only had some
clips out of context
right exactly never once do they show
you all of the clips and never once do
they mention the lengthy criminal record
of the victims uh you know you say
victims i say
assailants tomato you're a flying piece
of [ __ ] well and this
this just gives those channels like wait
said just an excuse to go well we can't
show them we can't show the video
we're just going to tell you the facts
without the video because youtube has
guidelines so
we can't show the video we're just going
to run a highlight reel of out of
context crowder quotes oh yeah she
didn't really apologize that was uh that
did not go like we expected
oh no intent to shock wait he's
monetized again during it
dang it we're using the term quite
loosely monetized [ __ ] so
uh anyway this is something that's
really concerning to me and something to
watch
for the election because listen it is
their playground we will have to play by
their rules however
youtube if they were to apply these
community guidelines it does seem
selective because
we would have violated them many many
many many many times of course we have
the luxury of our communications with
youtube and all of our videos have been
under thorough review so at no point now
could youtube change their stance and
say that any of our content has been a
violation because we've talked to them
about it and they've reviewed every
single one unless they suck at their job
so they would have to retroactively
change it in which case
every news channel could be banned yeah
absolutely i don't know
their goal i thought was to make sure
the public was getting accurate
information
i thought no that's what they say right
i know it's very laughable
no they say it right they're trying to
make sure that's what they say
you can repeat that phrase and stop i
thought
no you're not even just before just i
yeah because you didn't think no
no no exactly i thought that's what they
said they wanted
they wanted accurate information to the
public they wanted them to be informed
and not just have information going out
to shock them
exactly the authoritative sources
speaking of facts let's get to the facts
of
uh chris cuomo i can't wait till we do
our exhibition again
about for charity that uh he's been uh
um
so chris cuomo uh or as i call him the
lesser cuomo he's like
he's the equivalent to the promos what
the dillon brother is from entourage
oh yeah yeah the lesser true cuomo nice
you're matt dillon's brother
you're andrew cuomo's brother and your
dad was i mean you just you got this job
it is amazing
when they complain about nepotism at the
rnc by the way that's been going on
forever oh yeah it's the first
family now i don't want them coming in
an acting policy just because they're
writing of course the
the first man but uh i understand that
we want to know about the first family
we wish them well but you look at cnn
it's just a who's who
of of of swamp rats brian selter there
is no reason for that man to be
none whatsoever on national television
the dirt he has on somebody else's
sources please
she's amazing maybe cuomo because cuomo
as well shouldn't be on there yeah cuomo
is not he's not
it would be an insult to ron burgundy to
compare them
who was based on jim walcott in the
canadian show the newsroom and it would
be an insult to jim walcott
to compare chris cuomo all the way
around so
uh this is a recent call that was cut i
think tucker carlson had the exclusive
so hats off to him that's why we're
running this uh this clip
he was talking to michael cohen remember
that guy uh wanting to know
if the rumors and what's what's
concerning and i don't i'm saying these
are all alleged from chris cuomo
right um we don't know that they are
true and i would never accuse him of any
kind of actual sexual misconduct
right i just am curious as to what his
standard is and if it applies to himself
so here's him talking with michael cohen
assuming that there are rumors of sexual
misconduct
on his part asking if the rumors have
yet
spread you know i'm always careful
when i talk to media you know right
do you know how many phone calls i've
gotten from people at abc who say that
reporters
are calling and lying about things they
heard about me to try to get stories
about me when i was at abc
guys calling and saying i heard he was
the charlie rose of abc used to invite
women to the hotel and open his
uh bathroom do i look like the kind of
guy who's got to do that
hold up sure why not sure why not sure
why not
so i already have a good source that
says that he forced one woman to have
sex i just want to know if you've ever
heard anything like that
there is no woman right there is none of
this so here's the problem women who do
work there saying oh yeah you know
some of these men and naming me with
other guys you know we bumped into each
other once in the
elevator and he put his hand on my
shoulder and he made me really
uncomfortable
i mean what the it's it's it's a problem
and now you're so i'm careful with the
media always
i've always told you the media is not
your friend no oh
common ground not your friends
not your friend would you say the enemy
of the people yeah
one could say of the people oh hold on a
second really quickly before we continue
this
uh look trump again stokes baseless
fears of regulation they didn't say
strokes that's uh
that's good yeah yeah baseless for sure
the postal service let's just look at
new jersey michigan anywhere they've
done mail-in ballots not absentee
ballots ah you know
only a few dozen thousand votes that
didn't end up yeah you know yeah but jim
schudo told me it's baseless his name
is a meat garnish so cured
cuomo by the way first off it is a
legitimate defense he's not a bad
looking guy do i look at the kind who
kind of guy who would have to do that
but you might get a kick out of it yeah
exactly you know what i mean
it's not a sex crime it's a power crime
and obviously you know obviously it's
changed since you've done you know
a little bit of injections with
testosterone and
it's not entirely basis if you look at
chris cuomo you look at how he kind of
grew up and you see how thin his neck is
but then trapped that have gotten big
typically speaking someone who is
actually getting stronger you see it
with wrestlers or football players right
their neck gets big
along with their traps someone has big
traps in a skinny little pencil neck
like chris cuomo
typically means he's very weak and i
also know he's very weak because i've
watched his workout videos so the point
is
maybe you wouldn't have to do it because
you look good but maybe you would have
to exert some pressure because these
women
have seen your pathetic workout videos
it doesn't happen by accident stephen it
doesn't happen but
this doesn't happen by accident no it
happens with synthol
uh but he's saying you know the media is
not your friend this is complete bs
anyway
but have you guys heard this um what's
the standard for chris cuomo how does he
think
people should handle the kind of
allegations he's concerned about people
who say they are victims
should be believed and you have to know
that women don't come forward
often and for good and painful reason
post me too what matters to us or i
guess really the question is
what does not matter to us is it really
just about this president is he the
teflon don and if so what does that say
about
where we are and what we're about i
think we've seen enough of this now to
know the questions
the confusing part is what are our
answers
do me a favor and let me know um do
you let him know his twitter i believe
is chris cuomo and i want to be
don't harass no but ask him about the
standards and if he thinks these should
be applied to any woman who come forward
particularly the woman he's concerned
about you know you send him a message
and i don't mean you know
michael corleone says hello with a piano
wire because fredo i don't even think
that was fredo with the piano wire i
think fredo
who did they kill with the no that
wasn't the piano wire fredo was just
you know he was just shameful shot him
he was just the one who brought great
shame to the family
so he believes that all women should be
believed okay well listen any
allegations come forward that's your
standard it's not
mine i don't believe you're guilty
unless proven in a court of law the
thing is you've destroyed careers mr
cuomo destroyed people's lives and you
try to do it with the president of the
united states
and we now know behind the scenes why
you're concerned because
you just said the media is not your
friend
so you're not our friend you're not
you're not our friend
and it's even worse because he tries to
claim that he's a journalist and
unbiased
let me be really clear in case you
didn't know this i am not an unbiased
journalist
okay i have a point of view i try to
substantiate it i have never
claimed to be unbiased as chris cuomo or
brian stelter
does so i want to be really clear about
that he is saying that he
is not your friend let's go to cnn right
now by the way
where they say trump does not mention
jacob blames uh jacob blake's
name during kenosha visit and they just
said donald trump defends shooter
accused of killing two people why don't
they show the clip they didn't show the
clip
it looks like youtube would take it down
youtube would take it down right
and they have to be uh you know up there
at the top as authoritative sources so
they can get youtube to take our stuff
down
nbc we know who the sponsors are
exerting pressure
and you lost so you know who said jacob
blake's name uh
the girl who called him for sexual
assault saying he was back and stole the
car
she said his name and also you know the
police they had his name as well because
they had a warrant for his arrest when
his name was on it
she wrote his name she made sure his
name was on file pretty much right so
his name is out there the criminal who
assaulted police officer after
assaulting a woman
again who had an arrest warrant his
name's well known okay so i don't know
that trump needed to say the name of the
criminal
yet again well i want to see i want to
see his portrait in stained glass
i'm at a certain point like i'm sorry if
it's if it's a sex offender
yeah who's then returning after
restraining order to
abuse the woman who he has charges
against
sex offending that person yeah listen
listen come on guys come on
let's let's not act as though this is
even close to george floyd or eric
garner eric garner 100 i agree with you
that was a cop who was ill-prepared
yeah uh when we talk about uh floyd
that's just a cop who was trained poorly
the cop didn't actually do anything
wrong did we lose the cnn there we go
it's bad
cnn sucks as it relates to jacob blake
this is a lot like a brown situation
there's really no two ways about it he
was completely in the wrong that officer
ideally could have used a chokehold but
you don't want that uh
so he had to shoot the guy who was going
for a knife in his floorboard so listen
you made your bed you can land it now
yeah in the cnn guys earlier this
morning at about 6am
asked the question of the i guess the
the state's attorney uh in wisconsin
saying
is there any situation where a police
officer's life could be in danger when
the suspect is walking away from them
framing that situation wanted i wanted
to yell yes but i'm like
he wasn't like walking away into a field
into a vehicle with a knife he was
walking
into a car i don't know that depends is
he walking into the horizon or is he
turning
and opening the door to a gun locker and
he did it
he did it with a straight face and the
answer that you got well i don't want to
get into hypotheticals this guy was a
total liberal by the way i don't want to
get into hypotheticals on what uh could
and could not be uh
hypothetical they do want to get a
hypothetical
it's like this the non-hypothetical
assaulted officer yes he was already he
already had a warrant out for his sexual
assault and domestic battery
and then he told the officers he had a
knife they told him to stop they tased
him it didn't work and then he was
reaching for a knife as he told them i'm
gonna i'm getting a knife
listen we don't need a hypothetical for
me that's enough
exactly i would have been yelling at cnn
had i not been trying to get my son back
to sleep
he's the only thing that kept me from
cursing this morning very loudly well
good i don't want his first words to be
shut up gerald oh that's not cursing um
what do you think they're half asian
bill
come on yeah oh wow he's really leaning
into it yeah yeah he's going to get his
[ __ ]
i'm going to get typecast yeah
i feel good about it now i want to get
to uh the story of portland
right now because there are so many
things that have taken place over the
last 24 hours in portland
and it's just amazing because this is a
story where they've tried to craft a
narrative and respond and rebut the
president we
talked about that yesterday right uh we
talked about portland yesterday on the
show where they were saying actually
this is wrong we're going to fact check
the president
on him talking about portland being
little blaze well there have been recent
developments that's why we started 20
minutes late today
then again look just look at the smile i
can't i i just i
can't even get the word that it's time
to to fact check that checkers
back check fact checkers fact checkers
backpacker
cash you
got the news it's so good i'm excited
guys i don't even know how i can talk
okay i don't have to introduce to
introduce it i can't stop it
my mouth is getting dry if you want to
wipe the smile off play stealth
yeah so let's introduce it before we get
to the macro
i just think like there have been a lot
of people on the left who've been saying
this on cnn
just selter is the most fun to show uh
because he's so easy to dislike like him
and skin cuomo like let's put in our
best slots
people who you wouldn't want to talk to
at a birthday party
like even if it were a children's
birthday party oh the worst part of it
would still be if cuobo
and stelter were somehow dads there your
kids are friends or something
usually you avoid it and go speak with
the parents but you're like you know
i'm gonna go in the bouncy hop yeah i'm
gonna go into bouncy hot with the kid
who wiped his boogers in the couch
cushion cause that's better than stealth
so again the question to you there is
another question here with portland do
you just think this is so
emblematic of the left it's like it's
just like there's it's not bird there's
nothing
it's a peaceful protest ah there's fiery
but mostly
just turn your head just 90 degrees
there to the left and you refute your
own argument
but it's more than that here's stelter
saying that people need to fact
check president trump on his comments on
portland
president trump wants to go on and sit
there for an hour and lie about portland
and seattle and kenosha and new york
city
what i don't get is why these primetime
stars allow it
and why management allows it the
president tonight is saying that all of
portland's been on fire for each
year everyone who lives in portland
knows that's a lie just go read the
local newspaper in portland
i understand why the president wants to
lie about that to try to win his
re-election
but why do these primetime stars put up
with it
why do they take it why do they sit
there and pretend like he's telling the
truth
when they know that he's lying to
millions of people
sadly lawrence i think it's about the
money and i think it's about the access
to power
well listen come on that's how you have
a career is money and access to power
what are you gonna say talent listen
brian stelter
there's no reason for him to be hosting
a show i know edna but it's absolutely
true this is a guy who is in there to
push an agenda and he has no reason
to be on any kind of a program let alone
prime time i don't know if
sunday morning is really considered
prime time but the point here is do you
also notice that he said why are these
star hosts he doesn't consider himself
among them
and he said these people in portland can
read any local paper well
not exactly a local paper but from cnn's
own
fact check along with a quote from
lieutenant rich chapman he's a spokesman
for
portland fire and rescue he said there
have been fires set just about
every night of the protest
and it goes on to say but we put out
most of them i don't care right
and most of the nights where there
hadn't been actual fires right
they were attempted fires they were put
out beforehand that's all but
this is from their own fire department
there have been fires almost every
single night hold on
here's another one uh what's 25 million
just just to account for this and you
know they're under counting it just like
detroit with the murders
25 million dollars in reported damages
and over 500
arrests so stealthers
so much fact it's your own set i don't
know why these networks are they hand on
the show map
son of a [ __ ] that's a lot of nuisance
money
don't say nick sandman's mirror name in
the mirror three times he shows up and
you and you have to give him money
again if i say next time my next seminar
he shows up and i have to give i don't
have 80 million dollars but i have to
give it
i have to give at the sandman in the
mirror
is stealth the only person in america
that doesn't understand how the english
language works and when you're like yeah
the entire city is on fire do you think
he meant like every square inch of the
city was on fire simultaneously
that happened that even a nuclear blast
couldn't make happen they but they put
them out
yeah it's like okay let's assume you
have a big house let's assume
you have a big farmhouse wealthy but you
have a farmhouse that's like i don't
know four thousand five thousand
right something big but reasonable
people live in the country okay and uh
every single night
one of your main rooms was lit ablaze by
someone who didn't live in that house
and then someone were to come out and
say oh my gosh that's really rough you
get your whole your house has been on
fire
here for the last month you think you're
like wow i was just the den
yeah yeah i didn't really like that
anyway
it's for the movement and even if you
lit it yourself but in this case it's
just a bunch of antifa
black lives matter [ __ ] yeah let's
go to your point really quickly but
first i actually want you to watch just
in case
you this is what they cannot show on cnn
and this is what we'll see if youtube
actually bans us from showing this
uh believe you're lying eyes this is
portland ablaze
that's not fire no
mostly peace i love how the nightclub
music is still playing that's those
little wavy things that look like
it's a flaming fire it's a flaming limon
vodka gone wrong
just throwing ikea desks in there
avert your eyes and this is by the way
this is also a technique that they use
as they go well there weren't there were
fire and they can
cannot even deny they said well there
were fires most nights but not all
nights
the only reason there were fires all
night is because he got that fire
extinguisher there
earlier and there would be fires
everywhere in the city if you weren't
able to put them out so this happens all
the time right yeah
they they do it with rand paul where he
goes you know they would have killed me
really
oh they shoved you a little bit and
you're complaining well just because it
was mitigated
right because someone took proactive
actions to make sure that they weren't
harmed
doesn't diminish the fact that you tried
to kill them
i've had that happen too that's what
happened when i had a transgender person
by the way this was banned on youtube or
it was
considered borderline when transgenders
attack that's what mashable got so
pissed off about because two
transgenders actually attacked me
one threw a hobo's lunch box at me or
pencil case sorry
along with a fidget spinner and what
does the feminist next to me say
well i think you're okay but what if i
happen to whip it at the
weekend through years of estrogen
therapy transgender and knock his block
off would you be saying the same thing
does it matter just because i'm more
effective than the guy who's confused
about his gender
sexual orientation and i mean that by
the way not
i'm not trying to be uh i'm not being
facetious the guy had a letterman's
jacket and a dress
just because he could do it before my
brain can even compute like what is is
that a guy is that a is that a woman is
that like is there something is this
like a costume party what's going on
was that thriller i don't know i'm
getting the fidget spinners thrown at me
and they go well you're okay it doesn't
matter if fires were put out there have
been attempted fires every night and
there have been successful fires
most nights according to cnn stelter so
you guys can tweet brian stelter along
with chris cuomo i think you should and
here's another one the guy who hates
president donald trump the mayor there
uh uh very reasonable mayor
mr ted wheeler well guess what just last
night they were trying to burn down
his apartment building don't know if
this will get banned but just so you
don't
believe you're lionized here's a clip
i thought that was the we're on your
side yeah it sounds like yeah
same white bro voice yeah exactly see
i'm proving it i'm an ally
what what what's that a shiv whoa
toothbrush with a roll of scotch tape oh
you're like the mcguire for
killing white guys that's terrible um
and brian stelter i just want to go back
to him real quick he never misses an
opportunity to
miss the point right and to bury facts
he let his
hatred of trump get so in the way of his
job
that he misses out on the fact that the
mispronounced fire secret yeah
secret crush right yeah a scorn to lover
potentially i don't know
he he misses out on the fact that people
are being killed
in these cities people are being hurt in
these cities buildings are being burned
that's the point the point that anybody
is making that is talking about riots
happening in these cities
is that people's lives are being
destroyed and you're like oh
it's not the entire city of portland how
dare you donald trump everybody needs to
get along with me and tell
everyone in the news media we have to
say donald trump everyone has been
killed yet
it's only 14 000 arrests across the
country 30 dead a billion damages
900 officer casualties and donald trump
is trying to ferment hatred
with his muscular shoulders and
the hair that wisps in the wind that is
strangely attractive i can't explain why
but i just
i just want to slap him hold on his
pants and
spank him why am i talking
that's going to be a lot of nuisance
money um but here's the thing here's
what's uh i don't want to say
i don't want to say that i take joy in
this i really don't because i want
people to be safe but i also think that
when people talk about femening hatred
when you say that the president
prays nazis exactly well guess what
you're trying to encourage
acts of violence because everyone here
if they were an actual nazi who are
gassing jews in his off time you know
not work hours
but you know but still even if it were
on his own time my main gripe with the
nazi still gassing jews
wouldn't be whether it's work hours or
if he's an independent contractor it's
not about the w-4
it would be primarily the gassing of
jews all of us would kick his ass all of
us would probably try and kill him
and dump his body somewhere in the
ozarks right so when you say that the
president
is a nazi and you show a clip where you
specifically edit out him condemning
white supremacists and neo-nazis
we ran this the other day i don't even
want to run it anymore because it seems
like every time we run it they just say
and he
praised white supremacists when you do
that you are guilty
of at the very least encouraging a
mindset
that can lead to violence it's not
saying we have a disagreement of opinion
me saying that brian stelter sounds
really feminine and he's a countless
hack
doesn't mean you guys need to go punch
somebody there are plenty of talentless
hacks just look at the youtube featured
list
but when you say they're a nazi that's a
bit different so i take no joy in it but
i would say this is justice the mayor of
portland
ted wheeler is now moving out of his
condo
because of rioters consistently burning
it down yeah they're people
by writers by writers you mean trump
supporters yeah is that that's what's
exactly yeah
and a plunger well they're just they're
warming up like doing the christmas
carol thing they're just
practicing that's all they're doing in
the streets right now he's like ready
for christmas yeah he's packing up
because of patriot prayer
he's packing up because of the people
praying outside of abortion clinics
yeah definitely this is the quote from
mayor ted wheeler of
portland who again accused our president
of being a nazi or endorsing nazis
he said it's best for me and for
everyone else's safety and peace to move
i want to express myself
i want to express here's the funniest
part i want to express my sincere
apologies for the damage to
our home what a [ __ ] bag right
you're apologizing to them for the
damage to your home how do you apologize
for them for the what
25 million dollars in damages to their
homes
asshat hey guys listen listen
i'm really sorry that my home is going
to be under renovations for a little
while
you're going to have to deal with
hammering i'm gonna have to go to the
catskills for a little bit i'm sorry
i feel your pain and the fear that you
are experiencing due to my position
it's unfair to all of you who have no
role
in the politics or in my administration
no no not experiencing fear due to your
position
experiencing fear due to your policy
mayor ted wheeler
yeah and when trump says he wants to
come in there and maybe clean up a
little bit no no
no no no please don't stay far away no
thanks
what do you think he has in his
apartment i think he's a volunteer
cleanup crew
right right right so again donald trump
this is why the american people see the
president as someone who's an advocate
for them
against the elite and it's amazing to me
that they don't see this when a guy goes
no our city is doing really well
when donald trump says well listen i
think we consider the national guard
fewer people would have to die
they go ah you're a nazi nazi by saying
fewer people these are mostly black
neighborhoods i don't want more blacks
today
frankly no no no they don't need it hey
by the way let's get uh let's get our
own private security detail to clean up
the fire in my house while i go to my
beach pad all right guys
i feel your pain no peace out
even though you want to raise taxes and
everybody that's not enough to appeal to
the middle class
ted wheeler you aren't protecting your
citizens and the president
the billionaire from new york city is
the one who is looking out for
by the way one of the few legitimate
roles of government their actual
safety and security and you don't care
and then you apologize to your voting
constituents for the damage that
happened to your house
i can't think of anything that would
make somebody more of a prick
exactly mr president we've got it
handled over mr president it's good
we've got it handled and you know what i
will be the bigger man here and step up
and apologize
for the damage that you've experienced
from my house
sorry i'm sorry that that's happened to
you but you know
when when ted we shouldn't be the only
people
with this story this should this should
be on every network i mean just flip the
roles just a little bit
off second amendment people walking up
to a republican governor who apparently
hasn't said anything about these
quote unquote vigilantes right that's
the narrative right now if they showed
up to his house and tried to burn it
down
it would be on every single media outlet
wall to wall
see we told you these people were
dangerous you should have listened to us
now it happened and we're like
we got we got to move on to the next uh
segment uh we need we need to keep going
don't say anything look at the mayor of
portland right now and the head of the
new it's
the top story in the news for the last
several days is leaving his condo
because it's been
at least burned partially or attempted
to they've attempted to burn it down
and what is mr king saying uh he's
talking about trump heads to north
carolina by and delivers speech on
schools
what about the mayor leaving his condo
who called the president a nazi and then
saw that his bachelor pad was getting
burned down so he's been forced to flee
like an enemy of war
shouldn't that be covered mr king maybe
it's not newsworthy nuisance money at a
reporter to go on down there and ask a
few questions
you might have a budget for that my god
i yeah you know what chris como is right
the media is not your friend
hey but speaking of which hit the
notification bell please
if you're on the youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
of course we do the show monday through
thursday uh 10 a.m eastern this morning
was a little late because we had to get
that ted wheeler too much story
and the next big event i think is
september 14th that we'll be doing a
live stream at night which uh takes a
lot out of me okay
now we're going to move on to uh even i
mean it's just this show should just be
called the hypocrisy hour hypocrisy hour
and a half
doesn't really have the right i'm gonna
make a stinger for that yeah we should
brenden get on that i was gonna say that
me
um getting working great ideas stephen
those who are muslims
we are actually going to show you how to
cut someone's hair socially distance
wow that's right so we actually have all
the tools so that i can cut someone's
hair
from eight feet away we didn't even just
go six we went eight feet away that's
even better so we're gonna be showing
that a little bit and uh that's
foreshadowing here a little bit
call call me uh call me twain because
it's a team um
in san francisco nancy pelosi
oh look at it i can't stop anything that
starts with nancy pelosi i love it you
know what
it's cause no one died like no one is
dead because i can't but but
they're just they're just very
embarrassed and i know that for people
in the public eye that's worse
yes nancy's already dead on the other
hand fate worse than death
fate worse than death is being denied
communion
like nancy pelosi because that's like
i'm a strong catholic they said no
[ __ ] i think the pope said [ __ ]
crazy when they went
crazy when she walks up in line they're
like no no no no
she's like okay so anyway
a point is in san francisco the salons
were closed as you all know right and
that's the whole thing the total
lockdown which really didn't help the
state a whole lot look at the top states
with lockdown look at how they perform
states without the lockdowns look at how
they performed we've done this segment
before
but this is funny because nancy pelosi
where salons were locked down
some footage uh i guess emerged
yesterday of nancy pelosi
emerging to get a blowout
at the salon here you go look at this
that's nancy pelosi i thought it was the
costume lady from the incredibles
that's what she looks like she looks
like a latina like she look at how
dark her hair is that's pelosi and
that's the uh and
i'm sure straight uh hairstyles totally
um
that's pelosi walking in like she looks
a little bit like like a drown
mouse well you see when she's not on
camera she turns into the evil form
right takes off the form and the
character she just pulls off her face
like mission impossible yeah yeah
you're like oh my god it's valkyrie but
i bet they're so glad they installed
those cameras
yeah what a hell of an advertisement for
ring doorbell
so there she is without her mascot again
rules for me not for thee but
just like the portland mayor the reason
this really matters is because nancy
pelosi didn't just
go out there and say hey you shouldn't
do this you should stay home she was on
the war
path accusing the president of killing
americans for
uh not obeying the laws that she
flagrantly disregards she's a clip
clearly it is the trump
virus well what are you trying to coin
the trump
virus trying to make the trump buyers
said
months ago let's wear a mask let's not
let socially distance instead of
having rallies and political whatever
they were
then more people would have followed his
lead as the president of the united
states
instead of being a bad example making it
like a manhood thing not to wear a mask
you know she's super pissed that she
can't coin phrases
this is the trump virus someone's like
oh i'm in the china virus she's like
shoot
no i would be trump virus uh stop trying
to make it a thing it's not gonna be
it's not no it's gonna be a thing if i
say it's a thing yeah but you were
denied communion so yeah
so yeah i'm sorry you'll have a whole
lot of respect for you and we're gonna
get this isn't the first time that she's
been hypocritical by the way of course
we're gonna
get to her in chinatown right uh but
before this we should tell people like
the concern here too is not just that
she's a hypocrite but she has
ended livelihoods in san francisco yeah
so i know some people lost their job the
salon job
yeah i have a friend narodic he used to
live in san francisco he got out thank
god
but his wife owns a salon and she had to
shut down because
she could not do business wait your
friend from san francisco has a salon
and a wife yeah well his wife has a
salon oh i'm correct
i was like i don't i'm gonna have to
fact check you or statistical anomaly
well maybe in oakland because
barbershops are a cultural thing
but yeah i mean it's a real thing no
well he's gotten out though
yes thank goodness and this is again we
talk about the elitism
why do you think that the american
middle class they overwhelmingly support
donald trump or in a way that at least
they support donald trump to a degree
that at least apologize as a left
because
you nancy pelosi have determined that
someone's livelihood
is not a worthy enough reason for
reopening the economy despite the fact
that young healthy people
uh really are at no greater risk with
the coronavirus than the flu right it's
because
you decided that them being able to earn
a living was not
really worth the price of purchasing
votes
from other groups that you're currently
actively seeking and so you
sorry you [ __ ] them you [ __ ] the
middle class with the salons nancy
pelosi that's what happens
and then you go in and get your hair cut
that's why people think the democrats
are elitist we have
cuomo well we should believe all
accusers but not myself
brian stelter saying well why are why
are the media
why are those in media and management
allowing this to happen well guess what
happens right there on cnn because
you're wrong you were fact checked by
your own source
then we have the mayor saying donald
trump's a nazi and portland is fine we
don't need help but now he's leaving his
condo because it's being burned down or
at least they're attempting to burn it
down repeatedly
and now we have nancy pelosi who says
your business should be shut down and
definitely because the coronavirus and
then she
waltzes on in there like nothing's ever
happened like a hairless drowned sewer
rats
and you wonder why the american people
find you elitist
and by also by proxy that means that's
why the black vote is overwhelmingly
starting to tip toward donald trump i
know you'll say only 36
or 19 compared to six that's a big
number change you've been taking the
middle class for granted you've been
taking black people for granted
you've been taking i don't want to say
women because this could be those with
vaginas for granted
and now they're going you know what i
think i'm more than my race i think i'm
more than well
i think more than that and i'm trying to
see
uh you know what maybe i shouldn't just
vote to tax the rich like a selfish
prick
maybe i should look and see who wants a
tide that raises all ships seems like
the guy who wants to uh actually enact
law and order and a guy who wants us all
to be able to go back to work and a guy
who wants everyone across the board to
pay less in taxes even though we already
have a progressive tax but that means
that the rich people get a little bit of
a break but i got a huge break
you know what i think this guy might be
looking out for me if they keep doing
this
and i can't see it not happening because
they've already set their feet in other
words there's going to be i guarantee
you
four five six seven eight more mayors
like ted wheeler oh of course
where they've already said we're fine
and we're gonna find out that they're
not fine no
they're right these people got started
in politics and
in the news before cell phones and so a
lot of
a lot of them didn't you know aren't
counting on people being able to video
their
oh yeah and ring doorbell being able to
take care of it right
actually yeah so the hypocrisy is much
more easy to see now
but yeah it's much more on display and
people can see it that will change the
votes well you know what the
the first instant uh incident of that
that i can remember
both would work instant instance
incident of that that i can remember is
congressman
clyburn and i think lewis uh when they
were walking up the capitol steps
and the tea party back then existed and
they were trying to accuse the tea party
of being racist
right don't tread on me right and uh
they said that they were spat on and
people yelled the n-word
right that's what they said and this was
andrew breitbart not the trademark
andrew breitbart the man
the man who was first to reserve at my
wedding okay uh
he was very clear he said if you have a
cell phone you're a journalist he wanted
everyone out there to be a citizen
journalist and he
once he'd reviewed some footage he knew
that okay this had never happened he
offered a hundred thousand dollars to
the united negro college fund i believe
is the fund that he
offered uh to anyone who could find any
footage and here's the thing i remember
when i saw this
this was pretty new you know people
weren't really doing a ton of news on
youtube
blogs were just opinion blogs it wasn't
the james o'keefe thing i hadn't done
the hidden healthcare sting i hadn't
done the antivesting
at this point it was just sort of seen
as a place where people talked to the
cameras
and those in the entertainment industry
didn't respect them because there were a
lot of people on youtube just looking in
the camera going
makeup and you're like this guy is not
going anywhere boy was i wrong
you didn't like my channel stephen
but there were there were multiple
angles with cell phones
multiple angles up close where you could
hear every word being spoken with
congressman clyburn and lewis i believe
it was those two
uh and no one at any point said the
n-word
at all and all you saw was someone
accidentally some spittle came out when
they were yelling you know like why are
you betraying the american people which
is a dog whistle for the jews i guess
well apparently
they were betraying the american people
and so andrew breitbart went out and
said anyone
anyone who can find any footage it never
existed the media just didn't cover it
then they tried to hang him on a shirley
charade video and they try to destroy
his career because i saw how effective
he could be
when the fact is it was actually bill
o'reilly who edited that tape at fox
news out of context it hurt him
and andrew breitbart could only redeem
himself and only get on major news
when he had the dick pics from anthony
weiner
and the media knew about the dick pics
and they denied it because they were
carrying his water and i remember
watching this this was the tipping point
anthony weiner was going to a press
conference he was i don't remember if it
was at
i don't think it was the waldorf it may
have been the omni in dc anthony weiner
was going to
give a press conference all of them were
complicit they knew the dick pics
existed
andrew breitbart actually had them and
he was going out there to blame andrew
breitbart for slandering his name and
lying about it right fabricating a story
and the media was going to report that
but instead
andrew breitbart like a boss walked up
onto the podium
and i remember people who worked they
told me you could hear breitbart's in
the building
and he said i have these pictures and i
would i choose not to release them
because i don't want to put his family
through that but you have dragged my
name through them
the only way he was able to get the
media to be honest
was to actually hijack anthony weiner
keep in mind
up until this very second in time
anthony weiner was primed
to run for president and the media loved
him and they
knew what was going on it required
andrew breitbart hijacking the c-span
feed and podium so now though a lot of
people who are younger take this for
granted
yeah it wasn't always this way andrew
breitbart himself was not able to break
through
until it was so undeniable sorry i'm
getting caught in a rabbit show but
i i think people need to actually go out
there and tout his legacy a little bit
more because it's sort of become a brand
and people see the site and sometimes
there's some baggage
andrew breitbart to know that man was to
love him even though we disagreed on a
whole lot yeah and the only reason this
nancy pelosi thing is a story is because
the owner of the salon released the
footage right so if you have this
footage you
can see the inside here's the thing
though nancy i think pelosi they've
responded and said she didn't know that
she was doing anything wrong
oh so she she said just like tom
selleck right now selling reverse
mortgages exactly
yeah i mean i don't know this isn't my
first rodeo
we will send you money people send you
they send you money and then you take
everything you've
here we go here we go here we go nelly
could stay in the home she loved so much
nellie there were a little memories that
meant even more
a reverse mortgage loan isn't get this
vest off of me you should take your home
it's a loan tax-free cash just when you
need it
just when you need it it's about making
your retirement
better no it's not taking it's about
taking your [ __ ]
i don't know what's going to happen to
their kids but are there no prisons
are there no poor houses don't get a
reverse mortgage
please don't find a place to land please
don't
i don't care what magnum p.i says uh
speaking of
speaking of the haircut yeah is what
really matters um we have been a
full-service employment studio here
because yeah yeah i got a haircut
yeah a lot of people can't get haircuts
like they want to go out um
out there because a lot of them are
closed down so we've been doing it for a
while and as a matter of fact i think
some of that's going on right now so
uh it's time to uh check in with the
team with people at work
like i said we want to make sure that
our employees are taken care of here
that they're
they're fed they can get their haircuts
we want to make sure that they're able
to be gainfully employed and we can see
all right yeah that's that's that's
enough let's um okay
oh man i didn't realize it's full
service no privacy or anything there
like just
full-on butt wax okay
you should probably do these and run
through well yeah you should definitely
yeah back to nancy pelosi it shouldn't
surprise anyone
the smile went to a half smile but it's
gonna come back because i know the next
clip
shouldn't surprise anyone that she's a
hypocrite because she wanted to blame
donald trump
was politically expedient but keep in
mind that while the pandemic was still
raging on
not only did nancy pelosi say that it
wasn't really a big deal
but because of reverse racism or really
this is this moment
is like a michael scott moment yeah it's
like look at my asian friend
i like spicy sauce
that's what she's doing where she was in
chinatown
telling everyone that it was fun keep in
mind this is while the pandemic was
raging
here's the clip of nancy pelosi you
should come to chinatown
yeah if you look closely he's operating
all throughout the world but we think
it's very safe to be in town
she's surrounded by asian she's in the
street in chinatown but the only one
holding
is a white guy like he's like he's about
to hit her over the head like wilma
flintstone
do you know what i mean what kind of
huts but do you have to have to level
any criticism of donald trump when he
was at this time taking action and
you're on the streets of chinatown
saying
we think it's great not only here but
all over the world people should come to
chinatown everybody should be out in the
streets we and we think it's safe
and then to go back a few months later
and go we never said it was safe
is killing people she delivered a
god-awful parody of funkytown with take
me to
chinatown oh that's what she did again
her desire to try and paint donald trump
as racist
unbelievable overrode uh her virtue
signaling and putting on a mask or
african garb like we saw before she's
one of those things she said why didn't
this administration do anything why
were you telling people to take you to
chinatown
why did you do that because you wanted
to think donald trump is racist and you
don't
really care about people's safety or
livelihood as seen by walking into that
salon once you clear it out like you're
a dead rat
it's like she walks in like she's a mob
boss only the difference is
at the very least and i'm not saying i
support the mafia right you know
like they have to work their way up they
have to be a soldier they work their way
up to a chief they work their way
way up to a boss they have to keep their
head on a swivel right there are some
risks there the only reason you can
clear a place out is not because you've
earned respect in the streets
it's because you just uh you're a
politician
you can take their stuff at least it's a
voluntary transaction with
you know the the heroin the cocaine the
sex slaves with them off you're not
saying i support it
no not that i support that i have
anyone or the hell's angels on speed
dial just because i'm from montreal
don't let it fool you i'm just saying
she really these people really think
that they have they only have the power
that we give them
so let's strip them of more of it
speaking of power
the the not the lesser cuomo chris
his brother here's another here's a
video of him
hugging um savannah georgia mayor uh
again where's the mask
it's a clear one and the reason that
he's doing
that is because his desire to show his
bro hug with a black guy
it was like pretty preceded his mask
fear mongering
i don't know you know in his brain you
know he's like oh my god all of a sudden
i don't have a mask but he's black and
i'm gonna look like i got a decision to
make ah
come over here brother get it in there
it's going to be great for my
re-election keep mine this was after
he'd issued a no mask
no service law there right now about to
say something there audio
no i i just assume his mask was up on
that mural
oh my gosh i feel like donald trump is
playing these guys like seven moves
ahead at times like he'll he'll do
something and say something and then
kind of like hold back the laughter
for another day or two until they walk
into the trap you don't even know why
this is so funny because you just had
several moves ahead go to cnn right now
what it says
biden to travel to kenosha wisconsin on
thursday
it's like a little brother you just want
to face palm yeah exactly give him a
second control of this
roller coaster tommy yeah he's like
oregon hey i'll
send in the national guard to help
donald trump condemn the violence
first day yes three days later bye's
like why did it condemn the violence
well he did
ha but i didn't hear it this morning
that's cause he did it three days ago
what are days stelter didn't say it
you need a sundial no i don't i don't
think so let's just get you for a nap
okay i [ __ ] myself again
i need a wipey my my son says that too
though so to be fair
he's going to kenosha wisconsin he's
last at
everything president nixon needs to
condemn this yeah
he's in an office joe where's gerald
ford
he's been dead for a while ah another
one too young he was 94.
well he smoked a pipe so
what does it have to do with anything
um hey listen actually we are going to
teach you how to do a social distancing
haircut here
for those exclusively uh who are members
of my club comm slash mug club
and chat it's gonna be a lot of fun and
reading of course
but right now youtube thank you ish
we're sorry
not so much you must go